when I came out of the mist every cell
in my body had a different electrical
charge I felt like I was burning from
the inside out but I learned to
manipulate them concentrate them even
transfer them on to something else like
static electricity
I could feel it moving to my body it was
so weird it took a while to get control
when I first got here I almost burned
the place down literally hold my hand -
that's actor Luke Mitchell showing off
his powers in the Marvel series agents
of shield Mitchell now those stars in
CBS's new dramas called the code is
Captain John Abraham Abe they call him
the show chronicles the lives of an
elite team of attorneys who serve in the
US Marine Corps and tonight's premiere
captain Abraham makes a case for
prosecuting his friends his mentor's
killer
Jason hunt was my co when I got shot he
personally made sure I got back on my
feet and he turned into one of the best
friends I've ever had last night he took
a knife wound on the wire and he bled
out on the operating table I know and
I'm sorry I'd like to request that we
bring the accused to Quantico for
court-martial this is the murder of an
officer and deserves the Varsity
furthermore I want to handle the
prosecution did you just say furthermore
I did furthermore cuz he's smart too
smart and gorgeous Mitchell joins us at
the table I love the opening premiere
because it starts with your mentor who
was in the military is killed by one of
his own men and then we're off to the
races because it does seem like a very
open and shut case yes your that's
watching so when you read this when you
read this script Luke you said I want to
play captain a because what man
the the Marine Corps is just a really
fascinating world but especially being a
lawyer in the Marine Corps it was just
something that I I really didn't know
anything about and that when I read the
scripts I just I mean this guy is I mean
they're all the best of the best of what
they do you know they're so smart and so
tough and so badass you know
yeah oh it's just something really
interesting to explore to me there's
such a lingo you have to learn to write
so the military uses lingo like devil
dogs means Marines boot refers to
someone fresh out of boot camp what was
it like learning all this new technology
terminology I felt like I was a you know
going back to school you know every
every episode they're throwing you know
new new words at me I'm like okay now I
need to know what this is you know and
you're not a lawyer by training
absolutely not you went to school you
pass Thank You Ally in that clip we just
saw your clean-shaven you are no longer
clean-shaven here for the moment so what
what did that do to your character
because you kind of look kind of young
yeah that's the first thing that did to
me it made me look young yeah for the
last three years I've had a pretty full
beard so the first thing that I asked my
new boss when I got this job was can I
keep some sort of facial hair and he's
like no it's not not you know in the
Marines has to be clean-shaven it's like
well just so you know I'm gonna go young
yeah anyway it's it's fun it's cool to
be able to change my look for different
characters yeah well there's such
reverence and respect for the military
clearly and and the issues that they
face and you touch on those through the
series right like traumatic brain injury
other things each and every very current
yeah yeah you know what else I like is
that you don't have to watch one to get
to know the other every every episode is
individual so there's a beginning and
middle and an end so if somebody wants
to join at midseason which they hope
that we open they don't you you're
instantly caught up to date with what's
going on and yeah absolutely I mean
there are some some really interesting
intertwining overarching stories between
the main characters as we get to know
each and every one of them throughout
the season but for the most part every
episode is a standalone and we hear if
you weren't acting Luke you would be a
tennis player because you're pretty good
on the tennis court well you know
professional tennis I like I like to
think I am but you know that didn't pan
out so well for me tennis was like my
main thing growing up and you know I did
want to be a professional tennis player
but uh I quit when I was about 19
because I wasn't good enough
well we're available for a doubles match
okay great
don't want they are on your team yeah
Mitchell good to have you here the code
premieres tonight at 9:00 8:00 central
right here on what network look see ya
CBS right back